el fiasco de la champions la final de la
copa más importante de europa se vio
empañada por un retraso de más de media
hora más de 30 minutos en los que las
autoridades intentaban contener el
ingreso masivo de aficionados sin
boletas o con tiquetes falsos mientras
los ojos del mundo esperaba en el
partido de real madrid contra el
liverpool
la policía de parís asegura que
ingresaron entre 30.000 y 40.000
personas más de las 80.000 que se
permiten en el estadio para el ministro
del interior francés la responsabilidad
del retraso recae sobre los aficionados
del equipo liverpool y la estrategia de
los jóvenes para ingresar de manera
irregular al estadio de la capital
francesa
lo que se encontró fue un fraude masivo
industrial y organizado de entradas
falsas leitte katy perry que se comprobó
que más del 15 por ciento de los
tiquetes eran falsos tras la primera
preselección es decir más de dos mil
seiscientos una cifra confirmada por la
uefa fifa y es que a pesar de que se
desplegaron más de siete mil policías
bomberos y guardias de seguridad el
radio de 200 metros alrededor del stade
france se vio rápidamente desbordado por
la afluencia de aficionados del equipo
inglés la ministra de deportes de
francia ha acusado al liverpool de dejar
solos a sus fanáticos mientras que el
club inglés devuelve la culpa a las
autoridades francesas
no queremos decir que lo hayamos hecho
todo bien está claro que no pero lo que
decimos es que hubo un cúmulo de
circunstancias
y dificultaron la huelga de transportes
la llegada tardía y el hecho de que no
supiéramos que no éramos capaces de
localizar realmente a las personas que
llegaban al estadio
la culpa es totalmente de la uefa de las
autoridades francesas y por eso vuelvo a
decir pediré una investigación completa
para asegurarnos de que llegamos a la
verdad
al menos 30 personas fueron detenidas
según la policía más de la mitad eran
ciudadanos británicos